where do you go after death
what is the right way to die
can death be overcome
and if it can what are the consequences
of such a thing
these questions are at the very heart of
eldon ring's story and in order to
answer them i want to go over a set of
bosses that are defined by their
relationship to death those being the
death birds the ancestral spirits the
tibia mariners the godskins the burial
watchdogs and the black knife assassins
understanding these bosses will teach
you so much
[Music]
in elden ring oneself is separated into
two distinct entities there's the body
which is one's physical self or
corporeal flesh and then there's the
spirit which is essentially the soul
that commonly persists after death
in the age of the earth tree the bodies
of the dead and their spirits are
returned to the earth tree this is done
by a process called herd tree burial
where great tree roots in catacomb
dungeons absorb the dead so that they
might be immortalized with the tree
but it was not always this way in fact
the entire culture of death had a
different shape in the earlier days of
the lands between
back then instead of old tree burial
death commonly burned in ghost flame
ghost flame also known as spirit flame
is a cold white flame that is created
when bones are burned to ash
we learn this from the fallen hawks who
prowl the underground rivers when the
last embers of their tortures were used
up they were forced to burn the bones of
their fellows instead and acquired the
cold ghost flame this process appears to
help separate the spirit from the body
and while a lot of these spirits appear
to be vengeful based on the ghost flame
spells i think in general having the
body separated from the spirit in this
way would have been a desired outcome i
speculate that we see proof of this even
in the current age where the wandering
dead at aguil lake gaze at the sky
praying that the dragon agile might burn
them to ash perhaps this was simply the
acceptable way to put a tired body to
rest
the keepers of ghost flame were the
death birds who tended to the flame in
their graveyards raking out the ashen
remains of the dead from their kilns so
i like to think of the death birds as
serving the old process of death and
delivering death by reducing bodies to
ash so that spirits might be better able
to move on now admittedly a lot of these
spirits are vengeful and that's how
ghost flame is sort of weaponized by the
death birds and sorcerers but i do think
that at its core ghost flame was
important just because it separated the
body and the spirit after all the
explosive ghost flame sorcery compares
this process of death to the urge trees
process of death which was pretty
all-encompassing so i think it's safe to
assume that ghost flame was just really
important to the process of death and it
was more than just you know vengeful
spirits and a weapon to be used
next we should talk about the twin bird
which was the mother of the death birds
we don't find this creature in game but
we can find its likeness painted vividly
upon a kite shield that one of the death
birds drops the design might remind you
of a phoenix which is traditionally
drawn with bright colours and a crest of
feathers and a longish neck
of course the phoenix is a creature that
rises from the ash when it dies which is
obviously extremely fitting for this
story so the kite shield tells us that
the twin bird or this phoenix creature
is said to be the mother of the death
birds but not only that it's also called
the envoy of an outer god so we can kind
of compare the twin bird to the two
fingers then who are also on voice to an
outer god they are on voice to the
greater will and similarly i assume the
twin bird probably communes with some
outer god of death and while we're
definitely left wondering what greater
purpose this outer god might have
the mere fact that it exists lends a lot
of significance to the twin bird and its
death birds as well
a variation on the death bird is the
death right bird which is an alternate
boss and it's a far more threatening foe
as it actually seems to use power that
it's gained from certain spirits and
ghost flame and if you look really
closely at its ethereal wings you might
even spy little spirits lurking within
and when i saw these i was really
excited because i recognized the weapon
they're using and the weapon explains
who they are
they're holding a little death ritual
spear and that item reads the priests
became the guardians of the birds
through the rite of death which is a
part of their contract for a far-off
resurrection so death boats have a lot
to do with sacrificial rights you know
they don't just attend to the ghost
flame they also deliver death and they
also perform rites of death so we can
assume that these priests were
sacrificed in a rite of death so that
they could lend a sort of spiritual
strength to the death birds but we're
still left wondering about the nature of
their contract with the death birds
which promises a far-off resurrection
for them you know what agreement did
these priests come to with the death
birds i wonder what has to happen for
their contract to be fulfilled and how
will they even be resurrected
in terms of where the death birds appear
they kind of appear everywhere and i
think that might be a hint that their
influence was once present far and wide
and while their importance in the
current age is likely quite diminished
they still definitely are relevant in
the lands between in fact many other
enemies actually make reference to them
and some even successfully channel their
powers even ghost flame lights the way
in catacomb dungeons to this day
but in general there is a lot of power
that can be gained from death in the
lands between which brings us to the
ancestral spirit
in the flourishing landscapes underneath
the lands between you would have found
the bodies of three large stags
enshrined by the ancestral followers
these warriors hunters and shamans
believe heavily in the principle that
life sprouts from birth but also from
death i think this principle is sort of
represented by horns because in real
life horns continue to grow throughout
the lifespans of animals with their
primary function usually being to convey
a social hierarchy and here the largest
and most influential creature is a giant
stag and in the world of eldon ring
since life continues after death it
makes sense then that this creature's
antlers continue to bud and grow even
after its death we learn this from
defeating the regal ancestor spirit and
looking at the horn of this fallen king
new growth spud glowing with light thus
does new life grow from death and from
death one obtains power
long-lived beasts like this are
worshiped by the ancestral followers a
race of beings who keep their distance
from the odd tree and are just content
to await new buds and new growth
if a being does not show signs of
budding horns or new growth then they
are sacrificed with an ax called the
winged great horn interestingly the twin
blades of this sacrificial axe are
called envoys wings which might be a
reference to the twin bird we mentioned
earlier which was also a winged envoy
according to the horn charm talismans
the ancestral spirits specifically arise
from long-lived beasts and i think this
touches on another commonly repeated
theme in elden ring which is that there
are benefits to living life to its
fullest potential
to quote some more death bird items the
most glorious end awaits those who cling
tenaciously to life and it is important
to render up a death worth offering
those who lived a heroic life were even
able to go on and see a unique version
of grace in the afterlife we currently
think that this grace is red and that
these are the same red rays of grace
that you might have noticed when you
first explored the forbidden lands so
this might be the most intriguing part
of the video let me explain past the
forbidden lands and deep within the
consecrated snow fields is a tibia
mariner and this one drops health and
steeple a great sword that reveals just
a mind-blowing amount of lore for one
item
first it reads greatsword patterned
after the black steeple of the helphen
the lampwood which guides the dead of
the spirit world so the word steeple is
commonly used to describe the tall spire
found on churches and indeed the design
of hellfin steeple echoes that of the
morian blade from dark souls which also
referenced the spire of a church however
while i think helpful is likely to be a
sort of church i don't think it's a
building instead this item seems to be
describing the shape of a black tree in
the spirit world a so-called lampwood or
lamplight tree that serves as a
guidepost for the heroic dead
the item goes on to say that lamplight
is similar to grace in appearance and it
is said that it can only be seen by
heroic spirits or those who met their
death in battle
so the black tree of hellfin is almost
like this dark mirror of the odd tree
but in the spirit world it's so
interesting that it even gives off its
own guidance of grace and
there's a few reasons we speculate that
this grace might be read
first a red gem can be found at the very
tip of health and steeple and a gem on
the rolled medallion as well plus
there's a red glow visible from the
sword's gem and a red glow from the
rolled medallion when you hold it up at
the grand lift where it takes you to the
forbidden lands where we speculate that
you can briefly glimpse this lamplight
or red grace filtering between the trees
so you might be asking why can we see
the grace when we're not dead but
technically tarnished are defined as the
dead who yet live so it might make some
sense that we can see it the next
question is where does the lamp light
lead and i think there's two options one
is that the lamp light might lead back
to healthin itself
that is the source of the light after
all and health and steeple can be
enriefed in ghost flames so maybe the
dead are sort of put to rest here
alternatively though i guess it's also
possible that the lamplight has plans
for the heroic dead just like grace has
plans for the tarnished it might lead
them somewhere else as well we just
don't know
in my discussions with quelaag who
helped with these theories she pointed
out the similarities that helfen has
with valhalla of nordic folklore if you
don't know valhalla is a place where
brave spirits would be invited to dine
with the gods and it seems that hellfin
is inspired by that same sort of
folklore since only heroic spirits can
see the light not to mention hell with
one l is actually the name of the world
of the dead in nordic folklore and
speaking of folklore this finally brings
us back to the tibia mariner the boss
that dropped health and steeple in the
first place the tibia mariners
themselves actually have no written law
to speak of which is kind of a shame but
what they do have is an incredible
visual design and it kind of carries
them from a law perspective because this
visual design is steeped very heavily in
appropriate folklore
so in greek mythology there is a stretch
of water called the river styx which
marks the boundary between earth and the
underworld and to help souls of the
deceased cross this river you have to
find the river boatman and pay him to
safely take you across
just so i kind of imagine the dead in
eldon ring are being drawn to the tibia
mariner in a similar fashion you know he
has a purple lantern and a loud horn and
he might offer a similar sort of
guidance to the underworld there is one
spell that references this boss briefly
it's tibias summons and it says for time
immemorial the dead have been those who
are lost and require guidance and
leadership
suffice to say death was a very
important facet of life in the lands
between even for the gods at one point
which brings us to the godskins an order
of apostles that were born to deliver
destined deaths to the gods long ago i
kind of like to think of them as a
counter-balancing force to the influence
of gods wielding sharp tools for boring
and slicing through flesh and encounting
spells that mocked the wrath of the gods
it seems these godskins actually
succeeded in hunting many gods if their
name is to be believed their robes were
made by sewing together patches of
smooth skin
and the noble's robes include
subcutaneous fat which makes them plump
and soft
known for their seven-faced aprons these
nobles are the most ancient apostles and
they're deeply inhuman their weapon is
not a slicer but a stitcher and they
wield it with a skill that is unmatched
by any lowborn
these beings were elevated to a social
class above the lowborn because they
served a queen a glomide queen the black
flames they wield are actually channeled
from that queen's greatsword and it was
this queen who raised them from birth in
the first place cradling her newborn
apostles in god's skin cloth so that
they might grow to become the death of
the gods
this glomide queen was powerful but what
makes her character so important is that
she was also an emperian chosen by the
fingers
now remember an imperian is a candidate
chosen by the two fingers to become a
god so despite being such a dark
character the glomide queen was still a
valid choice for godhood and all of this
of course was before the rune of death
had been removed from the elden ring and
it was from this rune of death that the
black flame originally got its power
we only know of one other imperian alive
at this time and that would have been
queen america
naturally at some point marika and the
glomide queen clashed though according
to the godslayer greatsword description
we know that the glomide queen was
defeated by malakath who was the shadow
of queen america he is credited with
defeating the glomide queen and the
apostles and sealing off the rune of
death which again was the source of
their power what's not clear to me about
all of this though is whether america
and the glomite queen were rival
empyreans competing for godhood
or if marika was already a god and
decided to take out the glomite queen
because the glomite queen was an
empyrean threat to her age but at any
rate it seems like america and the
gloomide queen are opposites you know
the glomide queen ends ages but america
wished for an age eternal so it makes
sense that they'd clash but there's
still so much we don't know about them
but after all of this america's age of
the earth tree began and during this age
you were supposed to wait for the roots
of the odd tree to call to you so that
your spirit could return to the odd tree
after death to be immortalized with it
specifically these roots were found in
catacomb dungeons and there's even a
statue found across the lands between
that was designed to help people find
these catacomb dungeons this is the
statue of roses the usher of death and
he shows the dead the path towards
catacomb dungeons the catacombs
themselves were built in the age of the
odd tree this is proven by root resin
which states that the roots here were
once linked to the earth tree and it was
for this reason that catacombs were
constructed around these great tree
roots so at this point in history queen
america had implemented her new concept
for death in the lands between and in
her eyes a proper death meant returning
to the odd tree thus in the days where
catacomb roots were connected to the old
tree these catacombs were valid sites of
earth tree burial and i think we
literally see this taking place as
corpses can be seen being absorbed by
the roots at the end of every catacomb
dungeon the process of artery burial
though is described as an honor reserved
for heroes
and this process of urgery burial is
presided over by earth tree burial
watchdogs who protects the catacombs
with their impish servants
these creatures are gollums and i think
that they might have been created
specifically during the period of
history where leonia had an allegiance
with lane dell since they served the
process of urgery burial but their
weapons actually have glintstone
embedded in them furthermore when hit by
impure crystal darts they malfunction
which i think is further proof of their
glindstone origins
in some catacombs and graveyards the
physical bodies of the dead have begun
to rise now these beings are defined as
those who live in death and they are a
relatively recent phenomenon in the
lands between instead of having their
body and spirit returned to the earth
tree they rise in an act that is
completely at odds with america's
concept of death ode tree burial and the
golden order
i'll go into more detail on this later
when we talk about godwin but basically
this all began when rani stole a
fragment of the rune of death from
malakath and then she imparted its power
onto the knives of the black knife
assassins you can tell the assassins
have quite a lot of secrets in their law
we do know a few things though we know
that they're all women they're all new
men and they have links to queen america
and the eternal city as well we'll have
to go into more detail on them later
though but with their knives imbued with
the rune of death they carved a curse
mark into two demigods ronnie and godwin
the curse mark itself is an obtainable
item and it reads this curse mark was
carved at the moment of death of the
first demigod and should have taken the
shape of a circle however two demigods
perished at the same time breaking the
curse mark into two half wheels
rani was the first of the demigods whose
flesh perished while the prince of death
perished in seoul alone so interestingly
these assassins and the knives imbued
with the rune of death had the power to
cleave life from the physical body and
from the spirit as well specifically
rani was the one whose flesh perished
and she became a disembodied spirit free
from her corporeal flesh which is what
she wanted and she now occupies a doll
but godwin became the prince of death
living without a soul and spreading the
rune of death across the lands between
through death root
now according to item descriptions death
root is the rune of death itself and it
acts as a source that gives rise to
those who live in death
now what i find really interesting is
the fact that this rune of death that is
embodied by death root and those who
live in death
it clearly has aspects of both death and
life as well which makes sense based on
what you should have learned from this
episode right because death isn't just
the end it's life as well so it makes
sense that those who live in death would
have aspects of death and life all
contained in these beings that were
brought to life in a sense by the rune
of death and while those who live in
death are a bit unnatural because they
do come from this fragmented rune of
death this half of a curse mark they
still have life in death and so you can
argue that they still have a right to
life and in fact that's entirely what
one of the endings is about at least how
i understand it and i'll try to explore
it more thoroughly later on these beings
are persecuted and hunted down by
fundamentalists of the golden order and
whether these fundamentalists are truly
serving the fundamentals of order in the
first place is just a topic that is very
interesting to explore so in conclusion
maybe it shouldn't be a sin to live in
death
after all to quote fear in death there
is only peace where in death there can
be no sensation
thank you for watching special thanks to
quailag for looking over this script she
has an awesome channel that you really
should go and check out and it's been
great to have someone to just discuss my
ideas with